[Music]
sylvester is in new haven connecticut hi
sylvester how are you
how are you doing i am doing mr daloni
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
how you doing today sir i'm calling on
behalf of me and my wife um we just have
a question we would like to know should
we sell our home right now do
tensolation because it's up to pay off
like that
and move into apartments for two years
and just try to save for another house
it's my last choice if you can't do it
any other way
so uh how much do you owe on your home
um right now we all got 114 000. what's
it worth
right now about 205. and how much debt
have you got not counting the house
um the debt is 70k uh 40 40 student
loans which is my wife and she has
another 15 and personal and i have 10
personal so we're around 70s
no car debt
no car deadline oh no we own our car but
we activate another car because we have
two children yeah so what uh what's your
car worth
um
it's uh
um
um insurance will they consider the
total loss so they'll give us probably
six thousand for it they won't fix
anything on it so
we'll get six thousand of each of these
that's the one that totaled what's the
other one worth
no we don't have one we need an
additional car oh so you have one that
you're out of cars right now
yeah we just have one car one car but we
need another one if we sell we'll be
probably able to get another car i got
you okay so what is your uh what's your
household income
um
honestly um i i make over six figures
with three incomes um
so my wife brings in maybe
um right now she's about to start a new
job which is around
60 social averages maybe 60 80 000 a
year right now she's trying to find so
you have a household income of like 200
000
uh at least 180 yeah that's what i'm
thinking yeah so
no you don't need to sell your house
how long have you been your wife your
wife's not been working until recently
oh yeah she just stopped she's you know
job searching looking for the right job
that you know how long has she been out
of work um maybe the past two months and
you know she just needed me time dealing
with the children and just you know no
i'm just i'm not picking on her i'm just
trying to find out where he's where this
math is going so basically you've had
over the last two or three years a
household income of 100 to 180 000
somewhere in there
i would say i was i i just got my
highest paying job this year so you
could say before that was w2s making 135
together because we owe every year in
taxes yeah and now we're at 180s yeah
well new haven connecticut two hundred
thousand dollars for a house is not a
fancy house
no it's a condo so that's why she she
would like to sell
take the game be
i'll move into an apartment with our
children for two years and hopefully buy
another home you know we're just active
asking for recommendations because we
spoke to other financial advisors and
he's like uh use your line of equity
yeah um you know it's up to you so
here's that financial advisor he's an
idiot yeah fire that person
so here's what you need to do i'm gonna
pick can i pick on you is that okay
absolutely so okay you make too much
money to be this broke y'all are
disorganized
out of control and overspending
you make a lot of money especially if we
get jacket all the way up to 180
thousand 180 thousand yeah we'll pay off
70 000 in about nine or ten months
but you know i granted you've not made
180 through this whole story
while you got into this mess
but the way you knocked this out is not
selling the house selling the house says
the debt is not the problem it's the
symptom
okay and you're treating the symptom
when you sell your house i'd rather you
treat the problem which is you guys get
on a tight budget
no eating out
no vacations
no life
and you pay all of this off in nine or
ten months
i mean how would it feel to be 10 months
from now have no debt but your house
that would be great that's that's the
ultimate plan yeah and then guess what
you can do figure it out yeah then that
condo goes up in value for the next
couple years while you're saving some
more money to add with that condo and
you can move into a little better house
which is really what your wife's trying
to pull off here without dealing with
the fact that you guys are overspending
like you're in congress
but you got to deal with that or dude
you're going to be broke your whole life
you can't out earn stupidity i tried it
for a long time
and you can't outlive this organization
and i've tried that for a long time
there's a lot of stress in this story
isn't there sylvester
yeah my wife is extremely stressed
that's why i have a job searching yeah
hold on hold on hold on hey you're
stressed too
when you're working i'm fine i'm fine
honestly it's my wife i care about and i
love it i just want to do that but if
you're all on your sword if you want but
dude the numbers you're giving me are
stressful if you're working three jobs
you you think you kind of know what
you're making what you're not that's a
that's hard right and you're you're
you're
you've got you're strong you you you go
to work you work hard there's some ego
there
but it's okay to say man i want to live
a more peaceful life too yeah if you had
no payments and all your money was doing
exactly what it was told you'd be
breathing deeper and one more step you
you mentioned your wife's got some debt
and you got some debt if you were so in
sync with her that this was y'all's debt
and this will be y'all working together
on getting out of this thing and then
your marriages you're going to look up
in a year after grinding this thing out
and y'all will have accomplished a big
hard thing together and then your
marriage is going to be in a place that
you didn't you don't remember it being
so here's the deal you're a good guy i
can tell by talking to you absolutely
you're a solid guy
um and uh i think you guys are almost
ready to do the smart stuff
if you are really ready
i'll give you financial peace university
the nine-week class for you to go
through you and your wife go through it
together
find a local church and plug into it or
get get on with an online group and go
through it with your online group and
then watch the videos and do the budgets
and do the stuff we teach you and in
literally in nine weeks i can show you
how this debt should be gone in nine
months and both of you be on the same
page
we can show you how to do it we've shown
10 million people how to do it
if i give that to you for free can you
get her to go along with you and the two
of you do these lessons together
well she's on the phone now if you don't
mind clicking in okay what's your friend
what's her name
my name is does she know about all this
discussion we've just been having
yes
sherry shay shay
yes hey i'm gonna give you guys
financial peace university if you'll
promise to actually go through it
together will you break that promise
yes if you guys will do this we can show
you how to get out of debt in 9 or 10
months 12 months max and you keep the
condo let the condo go up in value and
then you can move over and jump into the
better house later on that's about a
three-year plan or so does that sound
good
sounds good
okay you guys make too much money
because freaking broke you agree with
that
absolutely all right you hang on austin
will pick up and we'll help you guys get
through this you're you're the kind of
people we like to help
yeah she's on the phone this is bad this
good good good news right here john i
know and i love
man if i'm smiling ear to ear i love
talking to husbands who
have run up against like i'm trying i've
tried to
flex my way through this and i need to
go ask somebody for another plan because
my plan of just go go go it's not
working
and i'm looking around i got a stressed
wife i got strife kids i got debt maybe
maybe we can come up with a scheme to
get out of this and then i'm gonna go to
somebody and say hey i need some wisdom
and you say i got a path for you that's
got a path forward that's called a good
man it's called wisdom that's a good man
she married well good man
and she's a good lady yeah yeah he
jumped right in there i mean we have the
dragon kicking and screaming so this
this is the kind of folk that turn these
things they'll be on the stage doing a
debt-free scream in a year yep and um
and in five years they'll be telling me
their baby steps millionaires oh for
sure they're on their way because make
180 000. let me just tell you man new
haven connecticut not a cheap place to
live nope so um that's that's a big
market there so uh
it's a nice market but um yeah wow wow
very very cool and i'd love to hear
those three i'm working three jobs and
i'm making it happen
i love it yeah it's just so interesting
that
98 of winning at this stuff is just
deciding to do it yeah
it's exciting i'm not going to live like
this anymore so i was hiking the other
day my wife and i were on our
anniversary trip i was hiking up a hill
and
i think mental health i think financial
health physical health i think if we
distill it all down it comes into
three words do it anyway
let's do it anyway it's hard i need a
plan just go do it do it anyway go do it
anywhere anywhere i don't wanna have a
conversation with good to have good news
art williams talk just do it just yes
just
do it do it just on the right
love it